de nombreux états appel ressortissants à
quitter l'ukraine il modifie ou
réduisent la présence de leur personnel
diplomatique sont concernés les employés
d'organisations internationales qui
oeuvrent dans le donbass et notamment
l'organisation pour la sécurité et la
coopération en europe on retrouve notre
envoyé spécial dans l'est de l'ukraine
entonne claireaux
ce jeudi joe biden a appelé tous les
ressortissants américains à quitter
l'ukraine et cela vaut également pour
les ressortissants vers cas qui
travaillent au sein de l' os le à donner
pour autant que je sache les
représentants de l'osce et e du
royaume-uni et des états-unis ont reçu
l'ordre de leur supérieur de partir hier
les représentants de ces pays étaient
sur place je pense qu'ils vont quitter
le dombass c'est lors d'une rotation de
personnel effectué ce dimanche que les
membres américains mais aussi
britanniques de la mission de donner est
de l'organisation pour la sécurité et la
coopération en europe ont été remplacés
par leurs collègues d'autres
nationalités pour rappel la mission
spéciale du surveillance de l'eau et ses
oeufs dans le dombass a pour rôle de
tenter de faire baisser les tensions
mais aussi par exemple de documenter les
atteintes au cessez le feu conclu dans
le cadre des accords de nice et la
russie se dit inquiète de ce qu'elle
qualifie de relocalisation de personnel
de l'organisation pour la sécurité et la
coopération en europe jusqu'ici en
ukraine l'ouest et dont elle fait partie
réaction de la porte parole de la
diplomatie russe
la mission est délibérément entraîner
dans la psychose militariste fomenté par
washington est utilisé comme un
instrument pour une éventuelle
provocation
nous appelons les dirigeants de l'eau a
eu à empêcher résolument les tentatives
de manipulation de la mission et à ne
pas tolérer que l'organisation soit
entraînée dans les jeux politiques sans
scrupules qui se joue autour d'elle nous
partons du fait que les activités de
surveillance de la mission en pleine
conformité avec son mandat sont plus que
jamais nécessaires dans des conditions
d'exacerbation artificielle détention